il était un tout jeune garçon quand on
lui a offert ses premières jumelles il
raconte qu'elles sont devenues le
prolongement de ses yeux ornitologue
amateur depuis l'enfance aujourd'hui âgé
de 41 ans Jean-Noël rifel est toujours
éperdument amoureux des
oiseaux pour parler de l'observation des
oiseaux nous avons rendez-vous en bord
de Loire nous sommes tout près de la
pointe de courpin c'est là que Jean-Noël
rifffel nous a donné rendez-vous bonjour
Jean-Noël bonjour alors ce site d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'il représente pour vous
alors pour moi c'est un site où je vais
régulièrement faire mes révérences à la
Loire et aux oiseaux qui stationne sur
cette zone on est effectivement près de
la pointe de courpin et vous voyez que
devant nous on a un joli visuel sur la
Loire à la fois vers Lamont vers vers
Orléan et puis un peu plus loin vers la
Val et puis on est dans une zone où il y
a un certain nombre d'amas rocheux ù à
la faveur des étiage de la Loire vous
voyez que la Loire est assez basse les
oiseaux stationnent pour se reposer
faire une halte et notamment les oiseaux
migrateurs en cette période de migration
postnuptiale des oiseaux c'est un moment
privilégié moi c'est ce que j'appelle
les bonheurs de l'Aube c'est les
bonheurs de pouvoir rentrer en intimité
avec les oiseaux migrateurs donc en ce
moment on observe des éigrettes garzett
des Rongar de B ce regard sur la nature
l'environnement vous estimez que il se
perd un peu et donc vous militez pour
des récréations buissonnières c'est un
terme que vous employez qu'est-ce que il
signifie et je pense qu'il faut dès le
plus jeune âge apprendre aux enfants à
se perdre dans la nature la nature c'est
une expérience multi sensoriel comme
l'observation des oiseaux ça passe par
le regard par loui les CR les champs
d'oiseaux et il faut cultiver aussi moi
je trouve en tout cas moi c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire ces récréations
bisolinaires sont des moments où on
retrouve le silence le calme un autre
rapport au
[Musique]
temps on se retrouve chez vous Jean-Noël
rifel pour évoquer ce livre que vous
avez écrit ici éloge des oiseaux de
passage journal d'un ornitologue un peu
perché paru cette année aux éditions des
équateurs comment vous est venu l'envie
de partager votre passion alors vous
l'avez compris moi je ne suis qu'une
modeste plume et les oiseaux sont mon
ciel et donc ce ce livre c'était en fait
un un petit manifeste de réenchantement
du monde par l'observation des oiseaux
et mon idée c'était à la fois de
déclarer un champ d'amour aux oiseaux
puis à la fois aussi un cri d'alerte
face à leur disparition inquiétante
rapide et massive ces 800 millions
d'oiseaux qui ont disparu en l'esace de
40 ans en Europe il y a à la fois le
changement
climatique les pratiques parfois
agricoles qui sont trop intensive avec
une utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires qui évidemment fait
baisser la biomasse et les insectes et
qui touch les oiseaux insectivores il y
a l'urbanisation et l'artificialisation
des sols il y a aussi le trafic des
espèces
[Musique]
d'oiseau
vous êtes directeur de l'Office français
de la biodiversité et en centre valde
Loire et donc vous avez trouvé presque
un prolongement de votre passion dans
votre métier puisqueune partie de vos
missions consiste en la protection des
oiseaux expliquez-nous une des missions
de l'ofb c'est la police de
l'environnement et notamment la lutte
contre le trafic d'espèces protégé et
donc je vous ai apporté ici une
cachepiège donc ça en fait c'est un un
dispositif de capture utilisé par des
braconniers pour cap urer ce petit
oiseau ce chardoneray élégant qui a vu
30 % de ses effectifs diminuer en
l'espace d'une vingtaine d'années en
France à cause de ce trafic c'est un
oiseau qui est prisé pour son champ et
qui a fait l'objet d'un trafic depuis de
nombreuses années et donc il faut
effectivement lutter contre ce
braconnage he c'est le trafic des
espèces animales c'est le troisième
trafic au niveau mondial après les armes
et et les stupéfiants et des mesures de
protection des oiseaux impactent aussi
d'autres espèces effectivement les
oiseaux font partie d'un tout c'est le
continuum entre les êtres vivants c'est
ce tissu de la biodiversité donc c'est
un maillon de la chaîne qui permet des
oiseaux je rappelle permettent de
réguler aussi un certain nombre
d'insectes ravageur des chenilles
processionnaires avec les maisésanges
donc protéger un maillon de la chaîne
c'est protéger aussi l'ensemble par
effet papillon de la de la chaîne
alimentaire